l'objet de cette réforme depuis le
départ et moi je tiens à le rappeler
puisque je sais que vous partagez cette
préoccupation monsieur test c'est bien
de sauver de pérenniser notre système de
retraite par répartition donc les
conclusions qui vont sortir aujourd'hui
de cette CMP vont évidemment marqué
l'orientation qui va être tué derrière
personnellement moi je souhaite qu'on
aille au vote ça a été rappelé par
d'autres parlementaires sur ce plateau
avant moi le 49-3 moi me semblerait être
malvenu dans cette dans cette situation
donc voilà moi c'est le souhait qu'on
aille au vote après je veux aussi
dédramatiser sur la possible utilisation
du 49-3 c'est un outil constitutionnel
qui existe vous l'avez rappelé il y a
quelques minutes ça serait la centième
fois qu'il serait utilisé et quel que
soit les gouvernements de gauche de
droite du Centre on pourrait utiliser
avoir recours
avec vous puisque en tant que nouvelle
parlementaire moi j'ai eu à déplorer je
déplore le débat qui a été offert à
l'assemblée qui était offert par
l'Assemblée nationale pendant le débat
sur les retraites sur la première
lecture moi j'aurais souhaité qu'on
puisse aller au vote s'il y avait petite
obstruction parlementaire donc tout le
monde a décrié et donc aujourd'hui moi
je souhaite qu'on puisse aller au vote
en conscience que les parlementaires
puissent s'exprimer sur le sujet et
assumer leur responsabilité à préciser
par rapport à ce qu'a dit Monsieur test
tout à l'heure parce que j'ai entendu au
gré des LR dans les mesures qui sont
discutées aujourd'hui au sein de la CMP
il y avait des mesures que nous portions
aussi au sein de la majorité la mesure
des 43 ans sur les carrières longues je
rappelle que le groupe horizon qui a une
décomposante de la majorité le portait
également et que certaines personnes au
modem dont je fais partie nous étions
aussi sur cette ligne c'était important
de me laisser de casser cet effet de
seuil oui ça coûte alors après on a
l'équilibre budgétaire qui sera
effectivement à maintenir et ça c'est
une préoccupation également importante
des sénateurs c'est pour ça notamment
comme modèle nous avions défendu une
clause de revoyure que j'avais fait
adopter en commission des finances de
l'Assemblée nationale qui nous permettra
justement de rectifier le tir et de vous
expliquer en 2027 absolument et de voir
les seuil je rappellerai juste que 100
000 seniors de plus en emploi c'est un
milliard d'euros de recettes donc c'est
des thématiques qui sont extrêmement
importante et donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut qu'on puisse évoluer évaluer pardon
la réforme tout au cours je terminerai
juste sur ce texte il y avait également
des amendements importants sur les
femmes portées par le Mouvement
démocrate qui ont été intégrés par le
gouvernement avant l'arrivée en CMP
notamment sur le fait que vous allez les
femmes avant pour les naissances avant
2012 ne bénéficiez pas des trimestres
considérés comme cotisés et validé et là
ça sera bien pris en compte donc il y a
quand même des avancées sur le CDI
seniors si je peux juste réagir
je pense qu'il faut expérimenter le
dispositif ça a déjà été on a eu des
contrats de génération qui n'avaient pas
fonctionné la période des est différente
aujourd'hui le marché de l'emploi étendu
je pense qu'il faut y aller pour
expériment